ما الذي يشترك فيه سنجاب كاليفورنيا هذا
مع هؤلاء البشر الذين
يرنون للخدمة يمكن أن يقود شخصًا
بخفة ،
وسمعت هذا كضوضاء رنين متواصلة
كنت مثل ما يحدث وكان
زميلي في العمل مثل أوه لقد علمنا
السنجاب أن يقرع الجرس  يستمتع طلاب الدراسات العليا
والباحثون في
مختبر الأحياء الدقيقة هذا في بيركلي بإطعام
السنجاب الذي يأتي إلى حافة النافذة الخاصة بهم ،
لكنهم قاموا مؤخرًا بتدريب السنجاب
على قرع الجرس للحصول على علاج
رائع
أطلقوا عليه اسم كلوفر بعد أن تم جذب الملصقات
على الإنترنت لعالم الأحياء الدقيقة الشهير ألبرت كلوفر على
الرغم من أن شخصًا ما
أمسك بلوز واحد فقط بعد كل
ما أعتقد أننا لا نريد أن يعتمد السنجاب
علينا كمصدر رئيسي للطعام الذي
دربوه كلوفر عن طريق صنع
الجرس كلما توسل وإذا
حدث أنه ضرب الخيط وهو يلوح
بمخالبه  لقد حصل على عقدة لكن معرض الفول السوداني
اشتكى من صوت الجرس ،
لذا لم يخفضوا الخيط فحسب ، بل أعطوا
السنجاب قدحًا متدرجًا من البراز ، بل قمت
بإطالة الخيط ، نعم ، خضعت
للانتقاد قليلاً في
الكلمات الخالدة التي تزعجك
[موسيقى  ]
[تصفيق]
الآن فئران المختبر في خدمة
السنجاب
[تصفيق]
سي إن إن نيويورك